[Música]
o ataque eu tenho 61 anos 41 de
magistério 32 deles prazerosamente e
como forma de privilégio eu venho
trabalhando nessas corda na minha escola
que eu considero minha onde meus filhos
foram educados onde eu vejo gerações
educadas e por isso eu acho que eu posso
dizer pra vocês eu posso fazer duas
afirmativas vou começar como é simples
a mais simples diz que fazer escolhas
assusta e pode doer
agora eu posso fazer uma outra
incontestavelmente fazer escolha aos 16
17 18 anos assusta e quase sempre dói
deveria ser assim precisaria se assim
como foi a primeira vez em que eu me vi
frente a frente com o susto ea dor de
uma escolha assim eu tinha 18 anos
eu tinha a idade que meus alunos têm
hoje imagine a cena década de 70
sim eu sou da década de 70 do século 20
estou eu sentado no apartamento meus
pais tijucanos meu pai é advogado
formado depois de adulto não tinha
conseguido se formar durante a juventude
minha mãe com aquela classificação que
nunca me foi muito clara
chamada de do lar
ambas domésticos ficava em casa e eu
chego na frente deles e digo sua filha
mais velha perigo
eu depois de pensar em fazer engenharia
é não matemática engenharia não dito eo
direito medicina biologia estava direito
mas não era esse meu caminho e
decidissem na frente dos meus pais e
disse
o pai mãe eu vou fazer letras
melhor dizendo literatura e aí veio a
minha primeira percepção de como fazer
escolhas
é difícil e dói
imaginem a cena quando eu disse isso meu
pai olhou pra mim falou
mas minha filha você é tão inteligentes
que são subterrâneos
você é tão inteligente você escreve tão
bem
você fala tão bem literatura
mas isso quando ele disse isso o olhar
dele ficou desconsolado
a impressão que eu tinha 18 anos com a
minha opção é que eu estava de alguma
forma trazendo meu pai é alguma
insatisfação que ele pensava mais pra
mim e que eu não estava tendo atingindo
isso e eu disse sim literatura e como a
década de 70
acredito que poucos aqui lembrei disso
na década de 70 se você era como eu
o aluno dedicado acreditava que o
conhecimento é um valor
você só podia ir à universidade pública
claro que na universidade pública
estavam os melhores alunos graças a deus
não é mais assim
o mundo mudou há mais opções estão mais
abertos in foi para a universidade foi
feliz quatro anos
é o texto prazer do texto quando o
lombardi falando trazer prazer do texto
e ele nem me conhecia e claro mas é um
filme perfeitamente o que é o prazer do
texto
vivi essa desfeita segunda experiência
agora ainda de cunho pessoal
acabaram-se os primeiros quatro anos eu
sentei meus pais de novo disse pra eles
eu me inscrevi uma pós graduação já foi
aceita mas eu tomei uma decisão eu vou
fazer vestibular de novo e aí o meu pai
mas gms sendo com o rosto iluminado de
sa'a agora você vai fazer direito né
ele não vou fazer história e de novo
segundo a percepção do loroza meu pai
olhou pra mim
da primeira vez tinha sido literatura e
agora foi uma história minha filha sem
subtexto história minha filha você tem
que ser mais porque mas realmente
preocupado querendo saber eu não sei se
lá no fundo ele pensava
onde foi que eu errei com os amigos mas
eu disse pra ele eu descobri pai que uma
professora de literatura completa mais
próxima de dar a melhor formação o aluno
precisa saber muito de história e eu fui
pro sd novo fiz vestibular de novo mas
em oito anos no oeste e me formei a vida
continuou havendo os últimos 23 anos de
distante talvez 23
eu tenho passado o ensino médio e me
incomoda ainda hoje muito quando eu vejo
o adolescente 17 18 anos 16 anos na
mesma situação pelo mesmo motivo que eu
porque porque fazem escolha assusta
escolha dói
será que a gente disse isso pra eles o
suficientemente o que a gente pode fazer
por eles
eles agora tem muito mais possibilidades
se antes eu tinha direito e engenharia
medicina hoje em dia
caças ao a passagem dos tempos eles têm
relações internacionais gastronomia
existe tantas possibilidades de um jovem
se formar
e aí vem o final de ano em uma escola
como essa bilingue é um impacto é um
trabalho e uma cobrança
muitas vezes me sinto uma verdadeira
torturador é porque eu tenho sempre um
trabalho a mais e o que é que eu estou
fazendo para ajudar os meus alunos
mas não é só uma questão minha é uma
questão que nós discutimos muito a
coordenação e eu é o sonho
o bom de ter uma escola pequena como
essa é porque tudo parece funcionar como
se fosse o único órgão a preocupação de
uma preocupação de todos e eu fiquei me
perguntando o que eu faço o que nós
normalmente porque a família faz porque
talvez vocês não se dêem conta de qual é
assustador porque já passou muito tempo
pra vocês
quão assustador é o momento em que seu
filho a sua filha vai decidir alguma
coisa hoje em dia e voltar à
universidade pública eu vou pra
universidade particular é eu aplico pra
fora eu fico aqui que eu vou fazer da
minha vida será que eu vou ganhar
dinheiro será que eu escolher vai ser
exatamente aquilo que eu quero ser
aquela universidade que eu escolhi a
universidade certa
são tantas perguntas são muito mais
perguntas do que na década de 70
de um lado extremamente positivo mas tem
um lado que possivelmente é muito mais
assustador e aí então tá fácil o que a
gente faz com isso o primeiro que é o
que nós fazemos sempre acolhimento
acolhimento é essencial acolhimento das
famílias é acolhimento não acolhimento
do professor quando eu estou na sala de
aula e eu vejo por que esse tipo de
situação essa angústia ela de repente
sabe como ela pode ser manifestada num
aluno sentado na sala de aula e uma
lágrima zinha silenciosa
às vezes você passa no corredor existe
alguém no choro convulsivo
não importa o acolhimento ali você está
pronto no meu caso que me conhece já
sabe que eu estou pronta para o abraço
obviamente a gente acolhe a gente
dialoga primeiro compartilhar o disco
primeira colher e segundo é dialogar
ouvir falar tentar pensa pensa não é
assim pode ser não vai acolher e ouvir
esse aluno às vezes mais ou esse filho
esse amigo tá e vale com os amigos
mas que é objetivo dessa linha desejo de
falar
falta talvez algo que eu acho essencial
que a gente pode fazer melhor
compartilhamento de experiências
quanto mais a gente fala sobre isso mas
é fácil que você se reconheça no outro
que esse adolescente de hoje se
reconheça no na luta nessa sensação
naquilo que pode poderia ter sido
diferente para ele o que vai ser
compartilhar é essencial eu tenho algum
nesses 32 anos escolhe os últimos né
no ensino médio eu conhecer por exemplo
aluna que no 4º ano de medicina
uma família em que os avós eram médicos
os pais eram médicos irmãos eram médicos
ela vai fazer o que a medicina no quarto
ano já de medicina um dia podemos
conversar após podemos conversar e aí e
aí ela me diz medicina não é pra mim
desde mundo e não deveria ter feito isso
né quatro anos longe da escola mais
afetos num carro você sabe né e aí eu
fiz e ela disse que não pensa em outra
coisa
eu achei que a família toda fazia fiz
também eu não quero fazer mais isso
tentei dialogar colhi nessa altura já
era noiva já enfim ela o noivo
os pais serão tá bom você não precisa
acabamento você não precisa fazer se
você vai acabar nem se ela acabou
medicina pode soar interessante
vestibular
a comunicação foi trabalhar com
comunicação
durante anos ela trabalhou com
comunicação casou tem três filhos
há pouco tempo há muito pouco tempo a
medicina voltou a sinalizar pra ela você
sabe o que ela fez
ela foi fazer residência ela agora tem
três filhos em uma casa o marido e ela
tá fazendo residência que é fantástico
que mulher como eu fico feliz de ver
essa menina eu tenho por exemplo o
geógrafo
e à advogada que um dia chegaram pra mim
e disseram que eu não sei se eu quero
continuar trabalhando em empresas 2006 a
mesma coisa eu pensei em dar aulas e aí
normalmente ou possivelmente só um nome
eu fiz lá ela tá indo pelo caminho ele
pensou mais um pouco e decidiu que
aquela era a vida que ele queria
continuar
e talvez pra convencer você de
compartilhamento de experiências é
importante
há pouco tempo muito pouco tempo
alguns alunos aqui sabem saberia
exatamente dizer em que dia eu tive o
prazer de 13 aluno muito próximo tem
caído na sala durante a minha aula e que
é compartilhado com a turma a
experiência dele porque porque isso é
importante porque ele tinha colocado
como meta sem nenhum outro tipo de
abertura ele pensou vou para a alemanha
ponto tudo que eu quero aí para alemanha
e passados alguns meses agora a alemanha
morar fora estudar fora pode ser
diferente daquilo que a gente esperava
ele estava na frente da turma
conversando e eu olhando pra frente eu
perceber o interesse ele foi bombardeado
de perguntas
ele foi quem recebeu o tipo de atenção
que eu preciso lutar pra ter ou então
que eu tenho porque na realidade todo
mundo tem que fazer prova então gravam
tudo mas ninguém realmente eu tenho
minhas dúvidas se eles querem ouvir como
aquele rapaz foi ouvido com atenção com
vontade e aí eu pensei talvez seja isso
que falte
então a minha mensagem erro se você
conhece você tem um filho se você tem um
amigo se você professor como nós somos
e alguém está acabando
no médio três elementos são especiais
acolham dialoguem e compartilhem
experiências ajudem a vida seguir em
frente
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]